you're gonna operate this up
okay
um
great
okay so yeah the title of this talk is
theoretical foundations for data driven
algorithm design
and um my goal in this talk is to give
you a high level motivation of this area
and also tell you about the kinds of
questions
that we ask in this area and the key
challenges
so an important property of those
algorithms that are typically used in
practice is broad applicability the
ability to solve problems across diverse
domains
and i think this is perhaps best
illustrated by integer programming
solvers which are of course one of the
most popular tools for solving
combinatorial and oftentimes non-convex
problems and they just have a staggering
array of applications including routing
manufacturing scheduling planning
finance and many other areas
however these very broadly applicable
algorithms can oftentimes have
unsatisfactory default out of the box
performance
so for example they can have slow run
times return poor quality solutions
among other downfalls
and one of the key challenges is that
these very broadly applicable algorithms
often come with a ton of tunable
parameters so this is certainly true for
example of integer programming solvers
like c plex and group b
c plex for example comes with a 170 page
manual describing 172 different tunable
parameters
oftentimes domain experts are left to
tune these parameters by hand which is
just a notoriously time-consuming
tedious and error-prone process
but with a depth configuration of these
parameters these algorithms can be used
to solve very computationally
challenging problems
so this raises a question what's the
best configuration of these parameters
for my particular application domain at
hand
whatever configuration is best for
solving the routing problems that a
shipping company has to solve day after
day is probably not particularly well
suited for solving the scheduling
problems that an airline has to solve
another great example of a computational
problem with many different applications
is clustering and there are many
different clustering algorithms you
could use so here for example are five
different clustering algorithms which
i've used to cluster these three small
clustering instances and you can see
that some of these algorithms work
really well on some of the instances and
not so well on the others
so this raises the question how should i
select the best algorithm for my
particular application domain
well in practice we often have data
about the application domain in which
we'll be using these algorithms
data we could potentially harness for
the process of algorithm selection so
given a bunch of different algorithms
which algorithm should i use
algorithm configuration so given an
algorithm with a ton of tunable
parameters how should i tune that
algorithm's parameters
and even more broadly in the context of
algorithm design
so for example a shipping company will
have access to all of the routing
problems it had to solve day after day
a bio lab will have access to all of the
clustering problems it has to solve week
after week
and an airline will have access to all
of the scheduling problems it had to
solve over the course of the year
so the use of data together with machine
learning in the context of algorithm
design has been studied pretty
extensively over the past two decades or
so
and has led to breakthroughs in fields
such as constraint satisfaction
programming integer and linear
programming
designing algorithms for economic
context or mechanism design and
computational biology
among many other areas and here are just
a few of the very early papers to think
about using machine learning in these
algorithm design contexts
however almost all of this research over
the past two decades has been purely
applied they're surprisingly little
known about this topic from a
theoretical perspective
but this started to change about five
years ago and there's really been a
surge of interest in using machine
learning and data in the context of the
algorithm designed from a theoretical
perspective
and in the last half of this talk i'll
tell you a little bit about um
theoretical progress
on
data-driven algorithm configuration so
how should i tune my algorithms
parameters for my particular application
domain
okay so what would this look like how
might we hope to use machine learning in
the context of algorithm configuration
so first we would fix some parameterized
algorithm let's say c plex for integer
programming
and we would receive a training set of
typical problem instances for my
specific application domain at hand
and a bit more firmly we assume that
this training set of typical problem
instances is sampled from some unknown
application specific distribution
so for example this could be a
distribution
over the scheduling problem an airline
has to solve day after day
my training set is the set of all
scheduling problems this airline had to
solve over the course of a year
we run some optimizations and we return
a parameter setting which has good
average empirical performance over my
training set
and by performance i mean for example
good runtime solution quality memory
usage and so on
okay so this high level uh procedure
raises a few key questions first how
should i find a parameter setting which
has provably good performance over my
training set
this has been studied pretty extensively
from an applied perspective over the
past two decades but just in the past
few years there's really been a lot of
interest in this topic from a
theoretical perspective
and it's a very challenging problem and
lots of open questions for me
second no matter what parameter setting
i come up with can i somehow guarantee
that that parameter setting will also
have good expected performance
on future problems from the same
application but which aren't already in
my training set
so here expected performance is really a
proxy for future performance on future
problems that i'll encounter
and this topic we've also studied pretty
extensively over the past few years and
many different contexts including
integer programming
clustering computational biology
greedy algorithms and designing
algorithms for economic context or
mechanism configuration
so i just want to conclude with a high
level overview or what are the key
challenges improving these types of
theoretical guarantees in these
algorithm design contexts
and it's really about in these
combinatorial domains an algorithm's
performance is just a notoriously
volatile function of its parameters so
you could imagine for example i'm tuning
some parameter row along the horizontal
axis and i'm measuring performance on
some instance like runtime
and it's just a very volatile function
with many jump discontinuities
and intuitively this is because in these
combinatorial domains if you just tweak
an algorithm's parameters by a little
bit
you can cause a cascade of changes in
the algorithm's behavior which causes
these jumps in the algorithm's
performance
so overall the algorithm's performance
is just a very complex
function of its parameters
and this is unlike functions that we
really understand well from a
theoretical perspective in machine
learning where there's typically a
fairly straightforward connection
between a function's parameters and its
value on any given input
since we don't have this predictable
structure in the context of algorithm
configuration we have to understand
which structure is there which will
allow us to provide provable guarantees
um so with that i'll wrap up uh i'm
happy to talk about this more
in detail afterwards take any questions
thank you
any questions forever
it is very interesting uh can you point
on what's the inputs uh like a new
problem what are the things that you
know you look at to decide
yeah um so the input would be just for
example in the context of integer
programming it would be an integer
program itself so this could be
for example
um the scheduling
problem that an airline has to solve
today and we want to do this really
quickly
um using
data and machine learning and
information from all the scheduling
problems that we've had to solve in the
past
does that make sense i was wondering
like what are the like do you look at
the like the dimensions of the problem
or you know some similarities because
you have to have the previous data and
you want to see you know how does this
app or you know correlate with the
previous data yeah yeah so a lot of this
research not all of it has been under
the assumption that there's one single
fixed unknown distribution over the
problems that this we want to solve so
there's one distribution over the
scheduling problems that this airline
needs to solve and there are also been
relaxations but that's kind of the main
model that people have been working in
um
and then the guarantees that you give do
typically depend say on the number of
variables of the integer program or
something like that
all right thanks i think we'll save
other questions for the break uh join me
in thanking ellen and all the speakers
in this session
[Applause]
and we'll start again at 11 30